hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen lektion 52 hört
zu und spricht nach
aline sagt dass sie abnehmen möchte
aline
dass sie abnehmen möchte
stefan 4
das zu viel sport ungesund ist
stefan findet das zu viel sport ungesund
ist
elisa
jetzt glaubt dass veganes essen gesund
ist
elisa
glaubt dass veganes essen gesund ist
mein arzt sagt dass ich mehr wasser
trinken soll
mein arzt sagt dass sich mehr wasser
es stimmt dass ich den fehler gemacht
habe
es ist falsch das café ungesund ist
es ist richtig dass frauen den gleichen
lohn wie männer erhalten sollen
es ist wichtig dass man auf seine
gesundheit achtet
es ist klar
rinder und kühe viel co2 ausstoßen
dass rinder und kühe viel co2 ausstoßen
man kann
das dicke kinder auch dicke erwachsene
werden
nicht sagen dass dicke kinder auch dicke
erwachsene werden
hast du gewusst
das eine peperoni mehr vitamin c als
eine orange enthält
hast du gewusst dass eine peperoni mehr
vitamin c als eine orange enthält
habt ihr gewusst dass alle leute in der
schweiz eine krankenversicherung haben
müssen
habt ihr gewusst dass alle leute in der
schweiz eine krankenversicherung haben
müssen
ich bin mir sicher dass
sportliche leute länger leben
ich bin mir sicher dass sportliche leute
länger leben
ich bin der meinung
das biologische lebensmittel besser
schmecken
ich bin der meinung dass biologische
lebensmittel besser schmecken
ich denke dass vegetarier länger leben
ich denke
dass vegetarier länger leben
ich weiß dass es im gemüse oft pestizide
gibt
mir ist wichtig dass ich gesund bleibe
möchtest du ein bier möchtest du ein
bier
nein danke
ich darf
ertrinken
nein danke
ich darf kein bier trinken
warum darfst du kein bier trinken
ich mache eine diät ich will abnehmen
eine ernährungsberaterin hat mir gesagt
dass sich kein bier trinken soll
meine
ernährungsberaterin hat mir gesagt dass
ich kein bier trinken soll
zum frühstück hatte ich zwei spiegeleier
mit speck
zum frühstück hat
ich zwei spiegeleier mit speck
dazu habe
einen kaffee getrunken dazu habe ich
einen kaffee getrunken
zum frühstück hatte ich brot mit butter
und konfitüre zum frühstück hatte ich
brot mit butter und konfitüre
dazu habe ich einen orangensaft
getrunken
zum mittagessen hatte ich einen salat
dazu ein stück lachs und will 30
zum mittag
hatte ich einen salat dazu ein stück
lachs und wildreis
dazu habe
ich eine cola getrunken
dazu habe ich eine cola getrunken
zum abendessen hatte ich teigwaren mit
gemüse
gemüse dazu habe ich
als tee getrunken dazu habe ich einen
eistee getrunken